[Music]
approximately 7 million people around
the world die from heart attacks every
year and cardiovascular disease which
causes heart attacks and other problems
like strokes is the world's leading
killer so what causes a heart attack
like all muscles the heart needs oxygen
and during a heart attack it can't get
enough fatty deposits or plaques develop
on the walls of our coronary arteries
those are the vessels that supply
oxygenated blood to the heart these
plaques grow as we age sometimes getting
chunky pardoned or inflamed eventually
the plaques can turn into blockages if
one of the plaques ruptures or cracks a
blood clot will form around it in
minutes and a partially closed artery
can become completely blocked blood flow
is cut off to the cardiac muscle and the
oxygen starved cells start to die within
several minutes this is a myocardial
infarction or heart attack things can
rapidly deteriorate in the absence of
treatment the injured muscle may not be
able to pump blood as well and it's a
rhythm might be thrown off in the
worst-case scenario a heart attack
can cause sudden death and how do you
know that someone is having a heart
attack the most common symptom is chest
pain caused by the oxygen-deprived heart
muscle patients describe it as crushing
or vice-like it can radiate to the left
arm jaw back or abdomen but it's not
always as sudden and dramatic as it is
in the movies some people experience
nausea or shortness of breath symptoms
may be less prominent in women and the
elderly for them weakness and tiredness
may be the main signal and surprisingly
in many people especially those with
diabetes which affects the nerves that
carry pain a heart attack may be silent
if you think that someone might be
having a heart attack
the most important thing is to respond
quickly if you have access to emergency
medical services call them they're the
fastest way to get to a hospital taking
aspirin which thins the blood and
nitroglycerin which opens up the artery
can help keep the heart attack from
getting worse in the emergency room
doctors can diagnose a heart attack they
commonly use an electrocardiogram to
measure the heart's electrical activity
and a blood test to assess heart muscle
damage the patient is then taken to a
high-tech cardiac suite where tests are
done to locate the blockages
cardiologists can reopen the blocked
artery by inflating it with a balloon in
a procedure called an angioplasty
frequently they also insert a metal or
polymer stent that will hold the artery
open more extensive blockages might
require coronary artery bypass surgery
using a piece of vein or artery from
another part of the body heart surgeons
can reroute blood flow around the
blockage these procedures re-establish
circulation to the cardiac muscle
restoring heart function heart attack
treatment is advancing but prevention is
vital genetics and lifestyle factors
both affect your risk and the good news
is that you can change your lifestyle
exercise a healthy diet and weight loss
all lower the risk of heart attacks
whether you've had one before or not
doctors recommend exercising a few times
a week doing both aerobic activity and
strength training a heart-healthy diet
is low in sugar and saturated fats which
are both linked to heart disease so what
should you eat lots of fiber from
vegetables chicken and fish instead of
red meat whole grains and nuts like
walnuts and almonds all seem to be
beneficial a good diet and exercise plan
can also keep your weight in a healthy
range which will lower your heart attack
risk as well and of course medications
can also help prevent heart attacks
doctors often prescribe low-dose aspirin
for example particularly for patients
who've already had a heart attack and
for those known to be at high risk and
drugs that help manage risk factors like
high blood pressure cholesterol and
diabetes will make heart attacks less
likely to heart attacks may be common
but they don't have to be inevitable a
healthy diet avoiding tobacco use
staying fit and enjoying plenty of sleep
and lots of
after all go a long way in making sure
your body's most important muscle keeps
on beating
[Music]
you